dominique tricaud la voie qu'a chargée
de défendre les familles des victimes il
vient d'écrire au quai d'orsay
bonjour dominique tricaud merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et hier vous
avez donc écrit une lettre au ministre
de l'europe et des affaires étrangères
jean yves le drian quels sont les mots
de cette lettre et quel est le but de
cette missive exactement
depuis le début de cette affaire nous
avons la preuve que les gouvernements
français et britannique ne nous ont pas
tout dit
en dominant
en 2013 monsieur le drian qui était
ministre de la défense a dit au journal
de france 3 que la
l'angleterre je le cite n'a pas tout dit
les anglais n'ont pas tout dit donc ce
que nous demandons simplement à monsieur
de veilhan c'est de ça de dire ce qu'il
sait sur la responsabilité des anglais
qu'il n'y a aujourd'hui aucune raison de
cacher même si pour des raisons
diplomatiques en 2013 il ne voulait pas
en dire plus et vous pensez qu'en 2021
jean yves le drian peut en dire plus
surtout après ce qui s'est passé
récemment entre la france l'australie et
la grande bretagne
je me suis qu'avocat je ne fais pas de
géopolitique je dis simplement c'est
probablement la dernière chance pour les
familles
d'arriver à la vérité que le ministre
s'il a des informations une
responsabilité terré l'un devoir citoyen
et qu'il ne peut pas empêcher les
familles de parvenir à leur gueule parce
qu'on ne veut pas leur dire ce qui s'est
passé est ce que vous êtes en contact
avec jean yves le drian est ce qu'il a
répondu à votre lettre d'hier soir il
n'a pas répondu à notre lettre et je
veux espérer qu'il répondra avant le 22
octobre date de la fin de l'hymne quest
devant la royal court de londres et
comment est ce que vous analysez
justement cette première semaine de
deux procès
écoutez très intéressante parce que les
anglais démontre que lorsque les valeurs
supérieures sont en jeu il n'y a pas de
réussite que
l'angleterre axel de consacrer trois
semaines à ce procès ce que la france
n'a pas leur but faire donc je crois
qu'il faut saluer et remercier très
solennellement nos amis en
leur façon dont s'organise le procès ne
nous remplit pas d'optimisme car
l'unique experts appointés par le
coroner ne va pas dans le bon sens mais
le seul fait que trois semaines
d'audience permettent de remettre à la
surface de vérité vous venez de le
rappeler à sous marins hollandais qui
traînait là où il ne fallait pas sous
marin anglais qui étaient à quai ou
qu'ils n'y étaient pas tous ces éléments
réintroduit publiquement à mon avis
doivent permettre à des langues de se
délier justement donc des sauveteurs dit
avoir vu un sous marin près du lieu du
drame de son côté la royal navy à nier
cette semaine la présence de de ce type
de navires dans la zone est ce que les
premiers éléments de l'enquète évoqué
dans ce procès permettent d'apporter des
éléments de réponse j'ai envie de dire
qu'y croire les secouristes ou la royal
navy
la preuve on peut dire beaucoup de
mensonges c'est que un
autre sous marins britanniques en 2015
alors chers chalutier qu'il a manqué de
couler il s'est enfui et on a pu prouver
sa culpabilité que six mois après donc
ça veut dire c'est possible et 2 que les
marines se sauve une disent pas la
vérité nous avons aujourd'hui la preuve
qu'un sous marin et hollandais étaient
sur place d'ailleurs il ne conteste pas
la question de savoir si c'est ce qui
est arrivé après le naufrage pour
hypothétiquement participer au sauvetage
ou s'il est arrivé avant le naufrage qui
l'a provoqué ça c'est le débat autour du
bateau irlandais quant aux turbulents le
sous-marin anglais on nous a dit qu'il
était advenu porte qu'il n'y était pas
puis qu'il a eu une avarie a dit holland
choses contradictoires que nous
attendons que monsieur paul ce qui est
aujourd'hui retraité le commandant du
sous-marin nous dise la vérité quand il
va être entendue après demain il ne
resterait que 10 à 20% des
enregistrements des appels radio ou
téléphone où sont ils passés
écoutez le tout anglais qui faut le
demander mais avant d'aller chatouiller
nos amis anglais font peut dire que
l'igname 0 enregistrement au cross du
cap gris nez pour la simple raison que
l'interrupteur a été éteint une
demi-heure après le naufrage et rallumer
10 heures après donc là c'est pas des
enregistrements perdu c'est un
enregistrement qui a délibérément été
interrompue sans qu'on n'ait jamais pu
comprendre la cause d'une chanson tout
un petit peu et nous n'avons côté
français aucun enregistrement parce que
l'interrupteur a été fermée en 2016 la
justice française a expliqué tout à
l'heure vous auriez aimé que la justice
française accorde autant de temps que la
justice britannique la justice française
n'a pas pu expliquer donc les raisons de
ce drame est-ce qu'il peut s'agir quand
même tout simplement
accident de pêche selon vous c'est
vraiment les marines britanniques
françaises ou autres qui sont enfin les
n'est pas offert une démonstration
technique en cinq minutes mais la façon
dont on a retrouvé les tables du chalut
démontre de façon par celui que le câble
que le cac qui reliait le chalutier à
son salut a été tirée par ce que les
experts appellent une forces exogènes
alors les experts n'était pas dans l'eau
pour savoir la nature de cette force
exogènes mais à part c'est une baleine
est passée par là ce que perd c'est
l'improbable ceux qui paient des
milliers de tonnes qui peut accrocher un
câble sous la mer ça s'appelle un sous
marin
merci dominique tricaud d'avoir répondu
à nos questions après donc avoir écrit
on le rappelle à jean yves le drian hier
soir le ministre français des affaires
étrangères dans ce procès dont dupuy
gala de braise qui a commencé cette
semaine et qui se terminera un bleu
après la mi octobre c'est la fin donc 2